welcome to the GOP debate on Fox
Business
I am your moderator Neil Cavuto and I am
I so each of you knows the rules by now
you get to answer any questions
aimed at you directly as well as any
time another candidate specifically
addresses you by name wait Jeff what are
you doing what why are you making that
face it's just a spot I like to smile I
really like I smile a lot against wigs
weird yeah it is weird
anything is timing okay so the first
question is to senator Cruz there's been
recent controversy surrounding your
eligibility senator because of your
citizenship how do you respond to the
allegations well Neil what I find most
odd about these controversies is that
they've been debunked and dealt with
months ago by scholars and even mr.
Trump's own lawyers here until they were
most conveniently revealed again at a
time when his poll numbers saw decline
what's the over-under on how long it
takes Trump to say frankly frankly
fantastic okay they've never been better
other people okay other lawyers scholars
I would that trouble different this
stuff but other people is too
conservative other people might bring it
up other people are saying that Senator
Ted Cruz it might be ineligible I told
them though no but it's all other people
mr. Trump like who okay if not you which
people are making these accusations okay
this is frankly people okay senator Cruz
people are talking other people okay
truthfully they're talking about you
they're all talking about you not good
things okay truthfully not very nice
things they're saying about you okay so
Donald they meet two other people not
named Donald Trump who are making an
issue of my citizenship he opposed a
week okay I'm waiting at the polls
everyone knows you're Paul's a week I'd
like to adjust that sorry dr. Carson you
weren't address and believe mister
shrimpson everybody does that cute he is
yes I am pretty lovable see this kind of
discourse is exactly what I believe is
unproductive to the
go process and I think that finding
common ground is something that can be
done with anybody in this country I'd
like to respond what I believe he said
anybody are you even Christy you that
sort of a turd why are you even here now
if for a moment I could get back to the
punt and away from all of this silliness
of underhanded politics frankly that's
exactly what a cubed would say that
doesn't make sense well get a cigar you
argue that I was born and can on a
dogsled plate law
are you proud of me yet that's yet I
mean really holy is everybody everybody
please stop this fighting we all come
from the greatest country on the face of
the earth we just all need to believe in
what it was that once made us great and
I believe that as a unified America as a
kinder America we can once again find
ourselves home oh god bless us every one
life is full of sweet surprises every
day's a gift the Sun comes up and I can
feel it lift my spirit fills me up with
laughter all of you shut up I gaze you
nice bad this is a good bad
you're going to do dr. ben Carson who
sings bless us all from the Muppets yeah
you ain't with noisy kings and there you
have it for the Fox Fools business today
tune in next time where we share wood
chips up John Kasich thumbs if you like
this video subscribe by clicking my face
with a button above or these two videos
next to me they're playing and they're
free we put a lot of effort into this